we have almost made it through the
summer air conditioning season all the
repairs that come with that well now
we're going to move into fall when it's
time to start thinking about your heater
and taking care of that to talk with us
about that we have Scott Chester who is
the manager of bumble Breeze joins us
today how you doing I'm doing good
Kendall how you doing today good just
get through the summer okay I mean
everybody did get through the summer
thankfully we had a monsoon season yeah
this year not quite as bad as some other
years not quite as bad there are so many
changes coming to your industry right
that are going to cause price increases
in the foreseeable future
correct um come January the department
of energy is switching to a CR2 rating
which is basically they're changing the
way they're testing the equipment which
is going to make the manufacturers have
to engineer it differently also and then
what does Sear stand for Sears stands
for seasonal Energy Efficiency ratio
okay I like to call it miles per gallon
for air conditioning okay makes sense so
there has to be it's a standard that has
to be met correct that is going to
result in some changes in pricing right
correct they're going to be estimated
pricing go up about 15 to 25 percent and
then Energy Efficiency is going to be
going up also they're going to be
switching from 14 Seer which used to be
the least efficient to a 15 Seer so the
bottom line for homeowners or anybody
for that matter is what
you'll be saving money on on energy
bills okay paying a little bit more up
front perhaps is that right so you guys
in the meantime are trying to offset
some of those costs you have some
specials going on we do have some
specials of course the manufacturers are
trying to get rid of the inventory that
they do have that they won't be able to
sell come January 1st so we are having
some blowout end of the year summer
specials so an opportunity to save even
more money on the front save even more
money on the front end what should
people be doing to get ready now that
we're kind of getting out of the summer
and maybe won't be using the AC quite as
much what should people do to prepare to
use heaters should definitely have your
furnace checked up before heating season
starts make sure that we don't have any
gas leaks carbon monoxide leaks in the
home gas furnaces can be extremely
extremely dangerous and it's very
important to make sure they're running
in Tip-Top shape all right hopefully
people will take heeds Scott it's good
to have you with us thank you appreciate
it Scott Chester from Bumble Breeze for
more information you can give Bumble
Breeze call at that phone number
702-551-1614 or just go to the website
bumblebreeze.com learn more about those
savings that we were just talking about
we'll be right back